- Hi, I'm Lisa Mazzola,
and I'm an educator
at the Museum of Modern Art.
And we are here in MoMA's galleries
where I spend lots of time
with students and teachers
talking about works of
art in our collection.
I'm here to share with
you my five top tips
for engaging students with works of art.
One of the biggest challenges
the teachers tell me
they have with their students,
is getting them to slow down
and really look at a work of art.
The way that we focus students' attention
here at MoMA is by asking
open-ended questions.
What I mean by open-ended questions
are questions that don't
require a yes or no answer.
So what else do you notice,
the overall size right?
So now you're looking at this painting,
the actual painting and it's much larger.
Yeah, what else do you notice?
- That's so flat.
- [Lisa] Yeah, can you
tell me more about that?
What does that mean, it's so flat?
These types of questions
get the students comfortable
generating their own ideas
and making observations,
and even interpretations
about what they see
without needing any prior
knowledge about the work of art.
So once you get a lively discussion going
using open-ended questions, make sure to
validate your students'
responses and keep them focused
by restating their responses to the group.
It's really important to not give them
all the information up front, but slowly
start to layer the information in.
This will leave room for the students'
interpretations and ideas
in the conversation.
The original kind of seed of the idea was
this depicting this community,
this village, this place that he grew up.
But it's not exactly the
way that it was, right?
So he added some of these sort
of unrealistic things to it.
Not all students feel comfortable
talking in a large group.
Some of them might feel uncomfortable
sharing their thoughts or their ideas
with their fellow students.
To address the needs of those students,
I like to develop activities that engage
other learning styles,
like writing or drawing,
or even incorporate physical exercises
like taking on the pose or the gesture
of a particular figure in an artwork.
So someone asked the question about
does it have to be real or
does it have to be imaginary?
And it can be both, right?
This is just about you
playing with line and shape.
When you engage students
in other types of learning
in addition to dialogue,
you're now making room
for responses you might not
get through conversation alone.
If you can get your
students thinking about
personal experiences that
relate to the work of art,
that's a connection you're making.
And the more connections you can make,
the more engaged the students will be,
and the more information they're
ultimately going to learn.
It's this connection between
information and ideas
that really activates the students,
and oftentimes makes them want to
explore works of art on their own.
So you've asked questions, and you've
layered in information,
and you're engaged in
different types of activities,
and you're making connections.
So my last tip for you is reflection.
It's really important to take the time
to reflect and synthesize what
the students have learned.
There are a variety of ways to do this.
You can simply ask them
an open-ended question
about big ideas, or you
can ask them to consider
what they learned about the work of art
that they didn't know before.
You can also have them do some type
of drawing or writing activity.
Whatever you do, it's really important
to take the time to reflect
and synthesize their ideas.
- [Voiceover] Amazed.
- [Voiceover] I see a chair.
- [Voiceover] It looks like traffic.
(children murmuring)
- [Voiceover] It looks
like a road with cars.
- [Voiceover] It looks like
lights flashing on a screen.
- [Voiceover] A road with cars
and those boxes are schools.
- [Lisa] See how it's
got quiet for a second,
and when we got quiet, your
eyes really got in there
and then all of a sudden these things,
it looks like traffic,
it looks like a maze,
I see all the colors.
It looks like a board game, right?
Incorporating these five
tips into your teaching
will help you facilitate
deeper engagements
with your students and works of art.